[Musique]
j'ai encore perdu ton amour tu sais je
peux pas me souvenir de ce que j'en ai
fait je l'ai pourtant rangé comme il
fallait c'est pas croyable comme tout
disparaî mais j'ai trouvé dans mon
carnet à spirale tout mon honneur en
lettre capitale à l'encre bleu au vert
sympathique sous décollage à la gomme
arabique j'ai un he fouillé tous nos
secrets je n'ai rien trouvé dans le peu
qu'il restait sous quelques brouille au
fond sans
intérêt des boules de gomme et des
matins par frais mais j'ai gardé dans
mon carnet à spirale tout mon bonheur en
lettrre capitale à l'encre bleu au vertu
sympathique sous décollage à la Gor
Arabi j'ai encore perdu ton amour c'est
vrai mais après tout personne n'est
parfait si tu n'en as plus d'aut c'est
bien fait tant pis pour moi j'étais un
peu distrait je garderai dans mon carnet
à spirale tout mon bonheur en lettre
capitale à l'encre bleu vert sympathique
sous décollage à la
arabique j'ai encore perdu ton amour tu
sais
c'est pas croyable comme tout
disparaî si tu n'en a plus d'autres
c'estes bien
[Musique]
fait tant pis pour moi j'étais un peu
dist